[Music]
excellent Keanu Reeves is quickly
proving he is the most excellent of all
the dudes the actor who has been
lovingly dubbed the Internet's boyfriend
did pretty much the cutest thing ever
for a fan while filming Bill and Ted
faced the music in Slidell Louisiana
okay so here's what went down when
Slidell resident Stacey hunt and her
sons found out the a-lister would be
shooting his movie just on the street
from their house they decided to leave a
sign in their front lawn that read your
breathtaking the quote was a reference
to this moment between the matrix star
and the audience at a recent gaming
convention
cute right well just wait because it
gets so much cuter the sign caught the
attention of the 54 year olds who got
out of his car and wrote on the sign
Stacey you're breathtaking adding his
autograph but that wasn't all yeah
believe it or not it gets even better
Keano even took time to pose for a pic
with Stacey and her sons
so naturally Stacey took to Twitter to
share the snapshots of the sweet moment
writing a few cars stopped but then a
car stopped and there he was he actually
stopped Oh My heavens writer producer ed
Solomon also posted about the sign on
Twitter quote so yesterday the sign was
out on a lawn on the way to set Keano
jumped out of the car and did this
following the pinch me moment the hunt
family left another sign in the front
yard reading Thank You Keano
with two red hearts the villain Ted
threequel has been in the works for a
while now when et caught up with Keano
in 2016 he dished on what fans can
expect we have a new draft of the script
that just came in I have to read and
yeah we're still dealing with dough and
story but we're closer what can fans
expect is it what's the premise it's
funny it's about the pressure of Bill
and Ted having to have saved the world
and it not quite working out and the
toll it's taking on their families three
words to describe the three equal
bodacious
excellent good and a heart I know funny
okay
this is the kind of story the world
needs right now people of course will be
right here to keep you up-to-date on all
the things the Internet's boyfriend is
up to so make sure to keep it locked
right here on ET until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]